this video is sponsored by grammarly
[Music]
blink your eyes right now
a blink of an eye takes around 400
milliseconds
or 0.4 seconds
in that blink of an eye in that 400
milliseconds
240 000 stocks were traded on just these
stock exchanges
blink 240 000 shares blink 240 000
shares blink 240
000 shares and guess what
the majority of these stock trades
aren't even made by humans anymore
this is high-frequency trading
one nanosecond faster one clock cycle
faster is all you need to be
you know how a price changes that's when
the game is played
and when that one tick happens the world
is
divided into winners and losers
it's one of the things we have to
realize is not our human world anymore
it's the world of the machines
yeah high frequency trading is just a
segment of a much larger world
the world of algorithmic trading it's a
catch-all term
to describe trading strategies whose
success or failure
solely rely on speed of execution or
latency
oftentimes when we're looking at a
computer we blink our eye
things are already gone speed of
execution and latency is referring to
the amount of time it takes for me to
submit an order to the exchange
and receive information from the
exchange to me and oftentimes when we're
looking at high frequency trading
strategies we're not dealing with
seconds
milliseconds or even microseconds we're
dealing with nanoseconds
in the stock market right now what you
can picture is a bunch of algorithms
that are basically programmed to hide
and a bunch of algorithms that are
programmed to go find them
and act and all of that's great and it's
fine
and that's 70 percent of the united
states stock market 70
of the operating system formerly known
as your pension
your your mortgage and what could go
wrong
if you're gonna start your own high
frequency trading firm the hardest part
is not the actual trading
but selling people on why they should
give their money to you in the first
place
that's where grammarly comes in the
digital writing assistant i've been
using for i can't remember how many
years now
all you have to do is add the free
grammarly extension to your browser and
boom that's it
now whenever you write an email a google
doc which is what i use it for the most
or whatever else you write online
grammarly's ai powered writing assistant
will help you effortlessly compose bold
clear mistake free writing
so you can focus on what matters lending
that investor the employer the viewer
all you have to do is hover over
grammarly suggestions click on the
suggestion and you're done
and the best part grammarly is free so
you really have nothing to lose
but if you have big business goals you
might as well get the best of the best
grammarly premium because it will pay
for itself you get the basic grammar
spelling and punctuation corrections
with a ton more
vocabulary suggestions to replace boring
bland words with more vibrant ones
clarity suggestions to cut down on
unnecessary words and tone suggestions
to make sure the tone of your emotes are
professional and positive before hitting
send
first impressions matter and online a
lot of the time your writing is your
first impression
so make your first impression count by
pausing the video and going to
grammarly.com to sign up for your free
account
and get 20 off grammarly premium today
that's grammarly.com
jake tram with the link below
may 6 2010 the trillion dollar flash
crash
on may 1 2010 greece was drowning in
debt and was on the verge of defaulting
on that debt and going bankrupt
greece needed a bailout but to get a
bailout the people bailing them out
would need to see that greece is taking
measures to make sure they have enough
money to pay back the bailout
or in other words their creditors wanted
to make sure that they weren't just
throwing money into a sinking ship
for greek ministers a day of humiliation
they turned out to be told the price
their country would have to pay for a
massive bailout
by the eu and imf still the greek
parliament announced massively unpopular
austerity measures
a very inconspicuous term for cutting
the fat off of government spending
they will have to slash public spending
and increase taxes
the greek prime minister george
papandreou went on television and said
big sacrifices would be needed from the
greeks
catastrophe painful things that the
people of greece would have to pay for
because of their government's reckless
spending
30 billion euros worth of cuts public
sector wages frozen
some pensions reduced the tax on fuel
and alcohol
up 10 percent vat increased by
two percent greeks were not a fan of
these proposed measures
so greeks took to the streets by may 6
the greek parliament approved these
nasty austerity measures in exchange for
a 140 billion dollar bailout by the
european union and
international monetary fund after that
announcement the protests and riots
reached a boiling point
and everyone around the world including
those on wall street was witnessing
greece falling into chaos right before
their eyes
pushing the us stock market down
there's a riots on tv in greece and
every time they showed
the greek riots the market would drop a
little there's a ton of trading activity
in the u.s stock market and by 12 pm the
market was feeling extremely unstable
1 pm an hour later volatility in the
stock market was so high that the new
york stock exchange had to force trading
to slow down
1 33 to 2 25 pm a british stock trader
working out of his parents house
in a working-class suburb in the uk grew
sick of all these high-frequency trading
firms that have grown to dominate the
market over the years
so navendir soro decided that this would
be the day he would go up against them
head on
a david and goliath type story much like
the recent wall street vets versus hedge
fund debacle
so he starts spoofing the markets see
these high frequency trading firms use
computer algorithms to trade
if this happens do this if a bunch of
sell orders come in for a stock
it probably means that the price of that
stock is about to go down
so sell our shares and so on so what
ciro did was flood the market with a
bunch of sell orders
to trigger those algorithms from the hft
firms causing them to sell
their selling would trigger more selling
from other firms causing a
self-reinforcing cycle downward crashing
the market
in coding we call these infinite loops
recursion and before his cell orders go
through
he would cancel them leaving him
unscathed
2 30 p.m five minutes later volatility
was up more than 20
which is super high and the market was
headed downwards fast
2 32 p.m two minutes later a big
institutional investor waddell and reed
initiated a
giant sell order but if they sold
everything all at once it would tank the
price
so they used a trading algorithm to
spread the sale of parts
with one condition if the volume of sell
orders increased
it would speed up their selling since
they would have less of an impact on the
price
pretty reasonable under normal
conditions this is pretty normal for
institutional investors since they buy
and sell in such large quantities
but today that trading algorithm would
only help set the stage for the most
infamous flash crash
and the market continued to fall 2 37
p.m
five minutes later that giant sell order
led to even more trading from others in
the market
so much so that the data from the new
york stock exchange got backed up
causing other exchanges to declare that
they weren't able to get up-to-date data
from them
2 38 40 p.m one minute 40 seconds later
the market starts falling faster fear
spreads through wall street chatter
explodes screens start turning red
2 42 40 p.m four minutes later
the algos of high frequency traders got
triggered to start selling rapidly
since they dominate the market the
number of buy orders start to dry up
while the number of cell orders explode
shooting prices down
the flash crash begins panic ensues
wow almost a thousand points we call
this a capitulation
they're gonna probably halt trading we
can't stop the selling
and we're all just sitting there and
you're staring into oblivion you're like
you have
no idea what is about to happen i was
thinking that something
terrible has just happened something
indescribably horrible just happened the
market was gone you get a nauseous
feeling
it you're worried you you don't know is
the world coming to an end or what's
happening
right 2 46 p.m the dow jones collapses
around 9
and a trillion dollars is wiped off the
market all in the span of around 3
minutes
and 20 seconds
[Music]
by 3 pm the market recovers most of that
trillion dollar loss and things return
back to normal
over 2 billion shares were traded in the
span of 20 minutes
worth around 56 billion dollars this
event would later be known as the 2010
flash crash or the crash of 245.
to this day because of how complex the
market has grown
we still don't know for sure what cause
what and if you were to replay the same
sequence of events
identically there's no guarantee that it
would cause a flash crash again
that's the nature of complex systems but
one thing
is for sure high frequency traders
played an instrumental role
how much do high frequency traders
contribute to these flash crashes
and a general like fragility of the
markets
yeah it's a good question i'm glad you
asked it
flash crashers in my professional
opinion are actually made less
frequent due to the presence of high
frequency traders or in other words
flash crashes are made more frequent by
the absence of high frequency traders
now there's a bunch of smarter people
than me that did their own research into
these cme
the cme researchers at the cme did their
own research into what happened on may 6
and they issued a report
and i'd like to quote you just a couple
of sentences from there
there are people a lot smarter than me
and they came to the conclusion and i
quote
there is no visible support of the
notion that algorithmic trading models
deployed in the context of stock index
futures traded on the cme group
exchanges
caused the market fluctuations in
question referring to may 6.
furthermore we find no evidence in cme
stock index futures of any undue
concentration
of activity amongst algorithmic or any
other types of traders
it's difficult to attribute the
declining market action to any
concentration of high frequency traders
rather we suggest that hfts may have had
the effect
of providing a buoyant function in the
market
so what the cme here is actually saying
is that hfts actually acted as a shock
absorber
during a period where investors were
dumping investors
got taken control by animal spirits they
started panicking they started selling
but algorithms couldn't feel that fear
so even when s p e mini futures were
dumping
hft algorithms were still jumping in and
out continuously quoting
and they were absorbing the shocks on
the way down due to panic selling
so it's my opinion that my subtly my
opinion it's backed by the cm's own
internal
report that if hfts weren't present
in may 6 then the flash crash would have
actually been much worse than what it
was
what you may not know is that flash
crashes like these aren't anything new
this one just happened to be a really
bad one from 2006 to 2011 alone
there were at least 18 520 of these
we'll call them ultra fast black swan
events over 18 000
these crashes are not kind of things
that just happen once in a while they
are the normal
situation when algorithms get together
this ecosystem has optimized for speed
and as a result they all end up looking
pretty damn similar
and when you have a bunch of species
that all look the same you end up
sometimes in catastrophe it crashes
these things are not stable because
they're not that smart
since 2011 high frequency trading has
only grown
august 18 2011 12.679 seconds after 1208
pm
bloomberg releases this alert keyword
packers set to plan spin-off of pc
business
good news if you saw that and you
thought hmm i should buy some hp stock
because it's probably going to go up
you'd be correct but you'd be too late
because this is what happened in the
next 4 seconds of that alert going out
the hft algos do what's called sentiment
analysis
where they scrape through press releases
and websites to find certain keywords to
quantify the general sentiment of
something
sentiment analysis and came to that
conclusion and executed the trades
orders of magnitude faster than you ever
could
and you can bet that hft firms are doing
this right now in places like wall
street bets and stock twits
which serves as a great segue into the
limits of the human brain
it takes around two to three hours for a
person to really consume a scientific
journal
going down that spectrum it takes five
to ten minutes to consume the average
news article
three to ten seconds to read the average
tweet and then we get to the limit of
human decision making
a thousand milliseconds or one second if
you're an expert that limit might go
down to 650 milliseconds or
0.65 seconds but anything beyond that is
beyond the limit of how fast we can
process
information this is where algorithms and
high frequency trading
shines where the only limit is how fast
light can travel through fiber optic
cables
or through the air in the form of
microwave towers connecting exchanges
together
where instead of thinking of trades in
terms of years months days
hours it's a game of milliseconds even
nanoseconds
just to give you a sense of what
microseconds are it takes you
500 000 microseconds just to click a
mouse
but if you're a wall street algorithm
and you're five micro seconds behind
you're a loser by the time you've got to
the first word in a story about a bomb
exploding in baghdad
the algorithm has already gone through
and figured out the event it's figured
out the location
it's figured out the time the intensity
it's put that into a model and it's
traded oil futures before you've even
had the page download
and this is the world where machines
read the news and they know more about
it than you do
but of course if machines are reading it
they're probably also going to be
writing it
and if they're going to write it they'll
probably also put noise out there just
to confuse all the other machines
and you gotta wonder is this your world
anymore or is it the world of the
machines
let's say you're in kansas and you want
to buy a stock on the new york stock
exchange
let's say you want to buy gamestop at 10
to keep things simple
you submit your buy order in kansas that
data gets sent to the new york stock
exchange
and a bunch of sellers offer their
selling price to you the lowest selling
price wins the order and that stock is
sold to you
however if i'm a high frequency trader
and i want to make money off of your
order
all i have to do is get to your order
before all the other sellers see it
i know you're looking to buy at 10 so i
go to all the other sellers who haven't
seen that there's another buyer at 10
because i'm faster than you and i buy
from them at 9.99
a cheaper price and then i come back to
you and sell it to you for ten dollars
profiting one penny off of that
arbitrage that opportunity that only
exists for fractions of a second
a penny may not sound like much but
remember we're operating in the realm of
computers
computers that can find and perform
these exact traits millions of times a
day
a penny or even fractions of a penny per
algo trade at 40 million trades per day
equals four hundred thousand dollars a
day and that's just from one example
from a tiny firm 60 minutes interviewed
back in 2011
one can only imagine the profits bigger
firms are raking in
and their high-speed computers trade 40
million
shares every day it's kind of like
scalping where you
go to a concert buy up all the tickets
and then sell them back to people who
didn't get there
in time at a higher price your thoughts
yeah i wouldn't say hfts like scalping
at all really
scalping is based on technical analysis
as opposed to rigorous mathematical
models generated by quantitative
researchers that you know play with
petabytes of data
with scalping day traders try to make a
very large amount of small
trades in the hope that that will lead
to larger profits now while
you hear the words large amount of small
trades you might think that
those are characteristics in hft that is
true but like i said the rhyme and
reason
is totally different are there hft firms
that
enter into these trades for nanoseconds
to
uh to do scalping or is it
is it a longer timeframe than that i
wouldn't say that they entered to do
scalping because like i said when i
think of scalping i think it's like
technical analysis
you know uh you buy a bunch of times and
then you might lose a lot if you get
you buy the peak and then it falls and
you're like oh [ __ ] all the profits i
made on the way up scalping
have been eliminated on the way down so
when you look at it from this very
lucrative angle
it's easy to imagine why hft firms are
dumping millions
maybe even billions of dollars just to
squeeze out one more nanosecond just one
more millisecond
why 300 million dollars was spent to
connect international exchanges together
with a transatlantic fiber optic cable
why they're switching from fiber optic
cables to microwave towers because light
travels faster through the air than the
cables
why hft firms paid to have all their
servers in the basement of the new york
stock exchange
to make sure everyone has the same fiber
optic cable length to the exchange
why hft firms pay quant more than many
doctors
quant are the quantitative analysts who
design these algos
because their entire business model
revolves around just one thing
speed and speed is a pay to play game
the underlying asset you're trading
doesn't matter it can be stocks futures
currencies commodities whatever
understanding economics the fundamentals
of the company also doesn't matter
the only thing that matters is
outrunning the next guide to the front
of the line
what you need to understand is that high
frequency traders do not care about what
the asset they're trading is
it can be documented for all they care
it can be apple it can be dog
it can be a banana it can be skittles
the only thing they care about
is the price they see on the screen
because that price is subject to change
and all change leads to different
opportunity
so you want to make big money as a high
frequency trader
you want to participate in the speed
arbitrage what
exactly do these algos look like
there's two generic strategies that
quantitative trading firms
may employ that come to mind the first
is called price arbitrage
so the day-to-day of a trading firm
involves quoting
tens of thousands if not more securities
every day
and in doing so they're generating
theoretical values for dozens if not
hundreds of option complexes
so that means that if the price of an
option veers dramatically away from the
firm's theoretical value
they will either buy or sell that option
and push it
towards its theoretical value what they
deem is correct
now when they buy or sell that option
they'll capture what's called edge which
is just a fancy word for profit
and they'll secure that edge by hedging
out their newfound option exposure
with the options underlying futures
contract now capturing that edge
via price arbitrage is an extremely
competitive endeavor
often relying on speeds of several
hundred nanoseconds
so the second strategy this is the the
last strategy that i feel comfortable
publicly talking about is called
statistical arbitrage now
statistical arbitrage is sometimes
referred to as stat art
and it's a market neutral strategy that
takes advantage
of inefficiencies and pricing between
correlated groups of securities
and to give you a little example let's
say we have pepsi and coke
and these are just two securities but
like i said stat arm focuses on a group
of securities
so pepsi and coke have a very strong
correlation that has persisted over time
as two competing companies
now if pepsi and coke are trading like
this and pepsi's share price starts
falling and becomes uncorrelated
untethered from that
of coke then a trader will potentially
buy pepsi and sell coke
in anticipation that those two share
prices
eventually realign now while this
strategy is has the word arbitrage in
its statistical arbitrage
arbitrage is a bit of a misnomer here
given that the strategy is not truly
risk-free
so for example if pepsi you know comes
dislocated
but then it goes bankrupt then the
company would cease to exist and any
correlation that you previously
discovered
over a larger time period would prove
useless so the two strategies that come
to mind
price arbitrage and stat arbitrage and
these are just the well-known
easy to explain algorithms people know
about these hft firms are always on the
hunt for the next profitable algorithm
and pay big money
enforced with very strong non-disclosure
agreements for quants to design them
high frequency trading is shrouded in
mystery and has only recently come into
the spotlight a little bit
one huge benefit that hft has provided
for the markets is liquidity
meaning that whenever you want to buy or
sell a stock there's always a buyer or
seller right there ready to go
unlike something like physical real
estate the spread between what the price
buyers and sellers are asking for have
also gone dramatically down thanks to
hfts
yeah they lead to like you said lower
bid-ask spreads which saves retail
traders maybe only pennies on the order
and on the surface
you might ask yourself who cares about
pennies but in the grand scheme of
things that saves retail traders
billions of dollars annually
do you think there's a big opportunity
cost where we're employing like some of
these smartest minds and math
to make a few cents per trade when they
could be doing something
in regards to like space or something
what do you think
i thought of this a bit i don't think so
for starters
i'm kind of like more of a living lift
type person i don't think other people
have a role in telling you what to do
with your life
you know if somebody wants to be a
writer right if you want to paint paint
it's as simple as that for me but but
going beyond that to the actual tangible
implications of a mathematician working
on
uh on a quantum research desk as opposed
to you know a spaceship
um i think that hft still has a very
tangible impact on the world and and
their
contribution would be fine would be
useful in high frequency trading
and high frequency trading or the impact
of it stretches beyond financial markets
for example
let's say there's a newly a new company
that wants to go public
now they rely on quantitative trading
firms to market make for their ipo
the reason being is if investors don't
have confidence that there's a market
that there are participants that they
can sell their shares publicly after
the ipo then they'll be less inclined to
subscribe to that ipo and if they're
less inclined to subscribe to a given
company's share issuance
that company can't raise money and if
they can't raise their desired sums of
investment
then they can't produce products and
services
that at the end of the day benefit
people like me and you consumers
so if they can't produce those things
nothing new
happens there's no innovation and our
living standards just tend to stagnate
in your opinion is high frequency
trading fair
in terms of is high frequency trading
fair i think that's a difficult question
to answer
because fair is an extremely subjective
word that's shaped by
our own world views and influence by our
upbringings i like to flip the question
a little and ask
is hft unfair now when i think of unfair
i think that somebody is either being
coerced into some sort of transaction
or one party has some sort of inherent
advantage or systematic advantage
conferred to it by some partial arbiter
and that is not the case in high
frequency trading in high frequency
trading
your ability to turn a profit is
directly correlated
to the talent that you can hire and the
amount of capital that you have on your
disposal
there's nobody stopping you or anybody
else from starting your own high
frequency trading firm
so when two parties enter into a
transaction it's entirely voluntary
and whether the party on the other end
is an algorithm or a redditor
it really doesn't matter and it
shouldn't matter
so to answer your question is high
frequency trading fair
based on my professional evaluation i
would say it is fair
okay and your reasoning is because it's
not like the government is giving you
guys some
inherent advantage over retail investors
anyone can
buy the computers hire the developers
and quants and researchers etc
and do the same thing you guys are doing
so right pretty much like a free market
that's exactly it and and the exchanges
don't confer some sort of
privilege on us all the information
regarding
market makers is public online uh
all the information regarding how market
data is disseminated is public online
there's no fast track because you are a
high frequency trading firm
we get treated the same as everybody
else okay
new hair new jacket and no i do not
watch anime
or listen to kpop i just really like the
style and you guys can let me know what
you guys think of it in the comments
below if you want to support this
channel financially you can check out
grammarly with the link below
again i've been using grammarly for
years now way before youtube became a
thing and i really really enjoy using it
pretty much like every day
you can create your free account at
grammarly.com jaketran and you can also
get 20
off grammarly premium with the link
below coding jesus the guy you saw
sprinkled throughout this video he is a
quantitative developer
meaning that he's the one that actually
writes the code that runs these high
frequency trading algorithms among other
algorithms for trading in the markets
he does that full time and he has a
youtube channel that goes over the stuff
and it really helped me out with
researching this video
and he has like really clear
explanations that are still technical
but are easy enough to understand for
the average person i highly recommend
you guys check out the full interview we
did
on the second channel with the link
below where we go over what it's like
being a quantitative developer with the
difference between
a quant developer versus a quant
researcher versus a quad trader
and you can hear his full explanations
on his opinions which i think are really
really rational and really reasonable
too
and you can also check out his youtube
channel with the link below too if you
are new to this channel we make video
essays just like this one
every single week on the most thought
provoking stuff in the world of business
just like this video
and it's free so you can dislike and
unsubscribe and leave me your best hate
comments whenever you want
so you might as well click that
subscribe button with the red button
below because you have nothing to lose
and everything to gain other than that
you can follow me on instagram at
jaketrend.io where we go over behind the
scenes stuff day in the life kind of
stuff
many many many business memes that i
really enjoy
jaketrend.io that is gonna wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
so
you